gar nicht mehr da sitzen dann ist die
so ein verhalten eines ehemaligen
gebietsabtritte die man aus sicht des
impfkampagne würde wesentlich
einem untersuchungsausschuss des
könnte wäre das sehr gut noch einmal ich
osteuropäische länder
sieht so gesehen ein schiedsrichter
habe nämlich den eindruck dass es in
meine tesla automobil dass alle jetzt
auf gar keinen fall möglich sind und der
macht und zwar in diesem fall
armee kämpft und damit hat sie natürlich
vorankommt und ich glaube genau deswegen
ukraine krieg sondern natürlich auch
für diese ausgewogenheit haben wir uns
worte zu sprechen es ist aber etwas
gehandhabt ob ihm schäden anerkannt
ganzen globus umfassende blase und da
der politik zu hinterfragen
york times zu wladimir putin geäußert er
sache erledigt dann gibt es nur noch
dran das ändert aber nichts daran die
zurückkehren können und den menschen das
hat sie bekommen meine damen und herren
den osten nico ist eine zwischenstation
bundestages zu untersuchen auch die
erfolgreicher sein wenn man sowohl vor
nächsten woche gab es dann eine weitere
finde es sehr bedenklich diese macht in
unterstützung angeht von wirklich von
zwischen den beiden damen
auch weniger möglichkeiten hier nato
anderes ob man kriegsverbrechen
auch in der vergangenheit immer
westens dann leisten müsste und hier
und da sieht man doch dass es aus meiner
schon vorher diese generelle zögerliche
bundeskanzlers ich also was rechtfertigt
monetäre und meinungsmacht
für den waffenstillstand die position
eine freundschaft seite an der
werden oder nicht
westlichen hauptstädten in berlin zumal
noch twitter ist er vielleicht der
es dienstagabend in emotionaler
finde ich ist es im rahmen des der
ausrede eine sache die muss man dennoch
subjektive seite bei schröder ist die
ist es eben auch wichtig dass politik
entsprechend eingesetzt da geht es eben
für uns bevor wir tiefer oder richtig
hat sich nicht von ihm losgesagt und er
ist meine meine forderung muss sich mehr
einer hand und dann auch noch finde ich
ist mir sehr sympathisch weil es geht ja
und da ist jetzt vor allem das
als auch die nachteile offen und
kleinredet und verharmlost und das sehe
zusammenbringen und dass man da ziemlich
mächtigste mann der welt er ist auf
wirkung von impfungen und die nicht
staaten anzugreifen es sind tausende
geschichte also ich glaube das mag ja
der ukraine in diesem fall
kommt eine ganz wichtige komponente dazu
zurückhaltende art auch natürlich wenn
das verhalten von frau merkel sollte
dass er mit dem man befreundet ist also
ob ich gut als schiedsrichter bin weiß
gar nicht anders ja aber das führt uns
lauter krach und nicht ernst nehmen als
einen rechtlichen rahmen auch zu
nicht nach umfragen gemacht wird also ja
nachrichten tag liegt hinter uns
sicht nicht so eindeutig ist dass man
hat dafür heftige empörung geerntet der
im kanzleramt ein konzept geben könnte
bundesgesundheitsministerium glaube ich
ihn auch etwas zwielichtig aber gut das
transparent kommuniziert frau bislang
sicherheit dass wir jemand da nicht
ich bei gerhard schröder aktuell und
gekümmert werden wir unser an welchen
genau hingucken muss also ich bin da
jeden fall ein mächtiger mann er ist
schön dass sie dran gewesen sind wir
rein in den john bass gehen und das ist
lasst ihn in ruhe er wird diese
manche gehen davon aus über 20.000
man redet immer über
ich bin überrascht dass sie erst in der
sich nochmal selbst rechtfertigen was
diskutieren es gibt eine aktuelle
schaffen und gerade aber auf der
deutschland schickt panzer gegen putins
man mal einen in afghanistan krieg noch
auch an der stelle gefordert wir
die umfragen zum thema waffenlieferungen
sogenannten experten
fernbleiben bei der meinung wir sind am
friedensverhandlungen selensky und
sein dass schröder gern den freund putin
erfüllten erwartungen von impfungen also
in ein dilemma rein das müssen wir jetzt
freundschaft nicht aufgeben und er hat
als letzte frage zu dem thema heute
auch ein beeindruckender unternehmer und
sehr kritisch und sehr schöne stimmen
ich nicht aber tatsächlich glaube ich
praxis weil vom staat nicht zu erwarten
wollen keine zeit verlieren und kommen
europäischen ebene glaube ich müssen wir
brauchen eine transparente datenlage
ist ja nun eine meinung ich weiß denn
die region liebe zuschauer die sich
das darauf hinausläuft
umfrage bei rtl n tv wo über 60% ich
hat sie dazu gebracht der aufnahme der
sich hinter so ein paar alten panzern
dann ist gerd rüdiger nicht allein in
mal zurück den irakkrieg es ist generell
ende der sendung ankommt wir wünschen
truppen und tesla chef elon musk auf das
schon sehen wenn es ein waffenstillstand
die haben sich sicherlich verändert in
puccini müssten an einem tisch sitzen an
russische soldaten tragischerweise muss
jetzt direkt zu der these von herrn
noch mehr tun wir haben phänomene wie
hat aber putin ist nicht der freund vom
finden sie denn dass die impfkampagne
trotzdem stimme ich schon zu es ist
kroner krise die ängstlichkeit der
ist bei der frage von frau stock
herzlich willkommen meine damen und
was die spd angeht weil es ja jetzt alle
nach meinem kenntnisstand ist es ja
dass man mal der frage nachgeht mit mit
ist stellen schadenersatzansprüche an
versteckt und die nach vorne schiebt um
schröder einen bundeskanzler der schande
ich komme immer darauf an wie es ist ja
ukraine in die nato im jahr 2008 nicht
sich den kopf zu zerbrechen wie eine
einer persönlichen freundschaft zu
seitens er zu es gibt ja nicht mal mehr
das morgen abend wieder als machen sie
den letzten wochen und monaten aber das
soziale netzwerk twitter für 44
verinnerlichen müssen was das ist das
vielleicht bei den deutschen weit
generell gelungen ist in deutschland
wirklich sehr sehr viel macht jetzt in
herren bei den 85 plätzen sind meinungen
deutschen kennen gelernt habe
eigentlich recht ich rechtlich so dass
cäsar preller ja meine these ist es dass
schröder ja das ist es nicht er nutzt
man dazu sagen hier in der ukraine
aber ich meine ist müssen rechtliche
zimmermann eine interessante entwicklung
tief felix wir brauchen eher
möglichen partei franzen vision sich die
den tisch sitzen aber am ende auch 40
schröder mit russland verbunden sondern
gibt den muss russland zustimmen dem
politische lösung aussehen könnte am
kann ja nicht der maßstab sein der
die impfstoffhersteller also moderner
irgendwie raus zu kommen aus dass in
die börsen demokratie also die
ich antworte darauf last schröder in
also generell finde ich etwas schwierig
bereits gestorben und alles was die
glaube 65 prozent der deutschen den kurs
milliarden dollar was taugt er geparkt
zuzustimmen die zu verhindern denn 2014
wissenschaftlern die man hört und zwar
der hand einer person es wird aber auch
es gut
was russlands präsident wladimir putin
grenzen gesetzt werden so wie sie das
verbreitet hier eher zögerlich zu sein
schnittstellen auch gerade für die
ihn zeit eher kannst oder war aus für
von jeder von uns hat ein thema
zu betrachtenden frau strack zimmermann
impfschäden gemeldet werden müssen den
ende die keine lösung auf dem
maßstab muss sein und klar das oberste
das ist durchaus schon vorher zu tage
wird putin nur dann zustimmen wenn er
millionen ukraine und das was ich hier
abstimmung auf einer hauptversammlung
der staat unmoralisch handelt wenn er
auch durchaus noch durch eigene
astrazeneca johnson & johnson und bei
auch gesagt haben das ist der richtige
mitgebracht was ihn bewegt erzeugt oder
zu sagen ich bin eine große
berlin schon berlin ist am nächsten an
mit allen wissenschaftlern und nicht nur
panzer gegen die armee des russischen
forschung und wirklich auch zu sehen die
schlachtfeld ist und diese lösung könnte
nicht besser wenn wir zum beispiel die
schuhe an ihm ab der hat für die spd
war es die haben anfang des krieges
dass verschiedene aktionär
örtlichen gesundheitsämtern und dem
ukraine hier tut ist am ende die nato zu
von olaf scholz unterstützen
erobern will der gerade erneut ein
hat es dann die okkupation der krim
ziel ist wir wollen alle so schnell wie
den militärischen stand der dann
aber ich will doch dazu sagen putin wird
eigentümerstruktur von facebook sehen da
auf der einen seite die bevölkerung
weg wahrscheinlich die anteilseigener
ruhe
berufliche interessen und ja finanziell
präsidenten und ist alle masken
paul-ehrlich-institut anscheinend
entwickeln sich denn überhaupt
schockiert
seine zwecke sei es dort trotzdem zwei
befürworterin der impfung ich glaube
mit dem regierungs frommen was da
unterschiedlicher meinung sein können
war neben im land ist nicht dass man
gesagt hat sinngemäß kann das genaue
moskau immer nach wie vor es gibt keine
erreicht ist als sein sieg verkaufen
und tag und was ich sagen kann die
lag es ist ja auch was
das so aussehen dass die ost ukraine in
sehr viel getan übrigens auch für
zurückhaltend zu sein da scheint ist
unglaubliches lügen statement von sich
gibt es auch aktionäre ob das jetzt so
meinungsbildung 'nen auf den plattformen
möglich dass dieser krieg endet aber ich
schafft zu begrenzen tropez song wie
gegeben dann hat es den als einziger
schröder es
passiert das aber nicht immer
massiv aufruft sich impfen zu lassen und
erst dann den krieg beenden oder einen
verteidigen und ich glaube dass müssen
und dass es darüber ein ringen gibt wie
dass es wirklich das ist was uns
eigentlich der mächtigste mann der welt
so nicht rüber chip buschi jörges retten
kann er muss also etwas geholt haben
bereit ist auf städte auf regionen zu
eigentlich heute für eine kenntnisstand
deutschland und diese freundschaft wenn
gespräche die ich führe sind durchaus
entsprechendem umfang oder wird nicht
zitat nicht mehr dass das doch jetzt
ich kann das 100 prozent nachvollziehen
russland fällt mit der süd ukraine bis
viel demokratischer ist an der stelle
zeitenwende diaz vorgetäuscht die gibt
ist ohne schröder zu dieser form nicht
eine solche die ein solches unternehmen
viel macht hat man denn wenn man jetzt
an diesem zögern auch was gutes zu
gegeben hat und behauptet hat die
ich freue mich diese und andere themen
und wir brauchen vor allem im letzten
dann doch einen unterschied ich nenne es
russischer truppen in der ost ukraine
und ich glaube auch viele andere in
endlich auch die pazifisten in
andererseits wenn dadurch die impfung
entsprechend anerkannt und da sitzt das
waffenstillstand machen wenn geschlossen
dann wirkt der aggressor sozusagen
wieder zurückbringt zu einem normalen
da ist damit wir lernen für mögliche
würde ich mal ein fragezeichen
aufgestellt wird ein einziger mensch
was sie sagen wenn der freund immer
sieht seine beziehung zu zuzumuten
auch nichts mehr bringe der ukraine zu
hin zur krim dass das das ergebnis ist
sehr erfolgversprechend für eine
gegeben und jetzt eben diesen krieg
twitter kaufen wie groß ist denn die
mit meinem wunderbaren gästen zu
es nicht das denken in berlin geht nach
diesem land vertreten eben die
dransetzen und deswegen brauchen wir
finden es gibt ja dieses us case
deutschland verstehen und aufhören davon
man ihm die posten abnimmt wofür ich bin
seit august aber niemand von den
impfschäden passieren die menschen im
möglich und er benutzt ihn nicht mehr
verzichten wo freunde wo verwandte wo
auch einen guten und fairen wettbewerb
helfen weil russland den krieg ja
verbrechen die seien nicht von ihm nicht
künftige wählen jedenfalls dass das
belohnt und zwar durch land gewinnen das
diskutieren heute mit von der partie die
mal in der veröffentlichten und in der
der minister gefordert diesen fällen
überzeugung dass putin nicht die die die
alles das hätte es nicht gegeben wenn
bestimmt wie die kommunikation über
hässlicher wird muss man ihn heftig
macht der sozialen medien letztlich
außergerichtliche einigung und da ist
der restliche teil der welt ihm
was man jetzt schon im kopf mit sich
wie vor da hin zu sagen wir werden
öffentlichen leben
neben der verantwortung die hamas jetzt
den wir eben bei den sozialen netzwerken
diese freundschaft sollte man ihm lassen
zu reden dass man hier der ukraine nicht
ohnehin ganz schnell gewinnen würde
szenario dass es zu einer eskalation
die ehefrau wo der ehemann getötet wurde
die ukraine in der nato wäre da kann man
von russland verübt worden sondern von
politischen parteien traut sich zu sagen
zunächst muss ich sagen schröder ist
öffentlichen meinung zu geben bin
schminken damit man noch zu ihm halten
sind im verhältnis zu allen geimpften
preisgekrönte schriftstellerin nora
müssen wir sehen er wird glaube ich erst
ich sehe es aber auch dass man
regen stehen gelassen werden ja genau
und nicht weniger und mitleid bitte
gegenüber tritt und mit allem was für
twitter weltweit läuft das ein völlig
trägt und dass man also auch bewusst
später noch mal mit putin reden müssen
eben auch eine möglichkeit wenigstens
alles so vor sich dahin sichert und
spielt twitter ja auch sl eine plattform
auf der einen seite hat wir brauchen
nicht haben und da muss l macht jetzt
kommt dass es zu einem tatsächlich
kann und schröder ist dabei bot ihnen
ja das wollen wir einfach nur freiheit
bossong die zuletzt das buch die
nicht abhängig von putin er hat sich er
innerhalb von tagen das war ja damals
der ukrainischen armee also die lügerei
herrn schröder ist da auch eher geringer
sagen heute ist man immer schlauer das
also ich finde bei allem respekt auch
an einem waffenstillstand zustimmen wenn
vergessen für vergessen dass einfach
uns stets als politisch oder eben mit
helfen sollen frau keller können sie das
sprache der schwäche entsprechend
einen finanziellen ausgleich zu bekommen
immer weiter zu schminken die tiefen
auch klare spielregeln der politik vor
gespannt wie du das ist die
nicht viele aber es sind welche die da
unhaltbarer zustand in den usa gibt es
ermordet wurde hingerichtet wurde das
dieses denken beinhaltet nicht wir
zögerlich ist bei der lieferung von
transparent über vor und nachteile
auch seinen beitrag als unternehmer an
geschmeidigen meine generation und der
bündnisfall kommen könnte das liegt
die meinung und deswegen würde ich
stimmt auch das muss man abstreichen bei
die ost ukraine an ihnen gefallen es und
also auf jeden fall um ein paar zahlen
dass es mal anfing damit dass herr
diese grün-roten der dar und führen
auf der die beteiligten die sich dort
militärischen mitteln entgegentritt und
sind und denen sich man auch oder denen
ausgeprägt denke auch mit uli hosen ist
müssen putin beseitigen und dann können
aus russland geht weiter und
honoriert sondern die sprache der stärke
material weil die verhandlungen
falten und die schwarzen ringe um die
allem auf der europäischen ebene und es
was wir in butter gesehen haben ist
hat sich nicht in unser british
für freundschaften und
der stelle mit dazu liefern ja also ich
sprechen muss das um einfach vertrauen
neue ernst des lebens veröffentlichte
im übrigen wenn jemand anerkannt würde
seit jahren eine diskussion über die
gemessene meinung in deutschland hat
nato argument der waffengegner verstehen
seinen heutigen position aber ich möchte
einen landstreifen im süden der ukraine
wir wieder mit russland reden sondern
hochtrabende debatten über die rettung
tatsächlich den optimismus
er in seiner kalkulation sagt das kann
gleichzeitig will man hier im donbass
man sich von staatlicher seite annehmen
augen zu zu schminken man hat das
anmelden auch eine gewisse rolle spielen
bieler der chef des rk ii gesagt hat die
zu nennen das paul-ehrlich-institut
männerfreundschaften und dass wir das
kann man das überhaupt nicht vergleichen
geschichten verstrickt in moskau denn er
ist ob jetzt dann gleich sagen muss wir
der hand von wladimir putin wenn er sagt
allein im jahr 2020 wurde ihr neben den
und das heißt waffenlieferungen und
überhaupt erst in gang kommen wir reden
zerschlagung die kartellrechtliche
ich wiederhole mal ich möchte wenn sie
werden mit putin reden müssen und
habe mich doch sehr gewundert dass
wirklich in mario pohl passiert ist gar
also weiter von hier entfernt gebiete
entlang über mario pohl die stadt werde
natürlich im persönlichen definieren
muss und da muss der minister jetzt
des weltklimas und um die füße russen
als geschädigter dann sind es
nein das kann ich absolut nicht
das heißt was wir alle machen könnten
gesehen als er nach roger gefragt wurde
auch zu schaffen denn von den vorteilen
masken sind völlig unerheblich die
ist ein verbrecher und ich erwarte wenn
mich was meine meinung angeht überhaupt
den tragischen optimismus so muss man es
gerade schwere waffenlieferungen macht
berichtet davon dass allein im letzten
twitter verkauft wird für so viel geld
zerschlagung großer
müssen den konzern nicht zerschlagen
ist nicht erpressbar
heute abend bei frau bossong nochmal
deshalb müssen als bestimmte kanäle
müssen gerhard schröder ist halt immer
sagen das ist zynisch was herr schröder
dass er sich jetzt auch von der nato
liefern ich glaube die der weg führt
thomas-mann-preis auch der renommierte
nichts das heißt die bereitschaft hier
wäre unser twitter konto abzubestellen
helfen und dann zum schluss politiker
die ratten das thema ist viel zu wichtig
nie interessiert oder nur am rande
verstehen nicht dass es wirklich so ist
auch kassieren wollen bis hin zur krim
spektakuläre summen im monat von 156
erobert um am 9 mai dann einen möglichen
sich niemand einfach aber sie sind eben
würde ich sagen nein aber wir brauchen
offen halten das ist ukraine hat doch
er hat keine schwarzgeld geschäfte
internetkonzerne
er jetzt schon freund ist ja sehen dass
ich nicht mehr für mich wenden und dann
hughes joseph breitbach preis zuerkannt
über die these die verhandlungen
auch nur mehr als privatperson er ist
ich halte mal grundsätzlich gar nichts
jahr eine sechsstellige sechsstellige
über die gerichte insofern zehn jahren
ich glaube das würde insgesamt zu einer
sagt ich möchte mal wissen wie frau
fast nennen der amerikaner dass die
gibt es ja wirklich extrem viel und wenn
auf irgendeine art von
und dem massaker dort und gesagt hat
damit eine landverbindung zur krim hat
sie alle tragen also impfgeschädigte
und die müsste jetzt wieder aufleben die
zwischen russland ukraine kommen
momentan zwingend notwendig und die
klar sagt dass die freundschaft
unsere frieden unsere freiheit wird
gemacht davon bin ich fest überzeugt es
genau am richtigen ort weil ich nicht
um es nur derart zu überlassen lasst den
zumindest ein funktionierendes kartell
davon dass in einer an sich so eine
richtig halte und du tust es ja auch
merkel argumentiert verdammt noch mal
wir die ganzen zahlen der longo wie
verhandlungslösung ist wirklich sehr
euro bis 8 111 euro das ist schon die
sieg verkünden zu können
allgemeinen beruhigung beitragen wäre
überhaupt das ernsthaft in gang wenn die
ehemaliger bundeskanzler dieses landes
zahl von ihm geschädigten gemeldet
wird er aufhören vorher kein stück wird
schön dass sie da sind frauen
problem das wirklich noch viel viel
auch schon und die muster übrigens auch
ukraine diesen krieg gewinnen kann aus
das ist das was er jetzt will ob er
dass habe putin nicht angeordnet er hat
erkennen kann dass paul das foul sage
eigentlich zerstört ist durch worden
und wettbewerbsrecht das wirklich auch
momentan in der ukraine verteidigt und
die sport vor sich hin die usa haben das
paul absolut aber das ist ja interessant
patienten aufrechnen der leute die durch
gibt auch keine heimlich aufgenommenen
bundesregierung aber uns hat das gesagt
die frau hat neun angestellte in ihrem
leuten soll man den spaß wir sehen da
medien machte konzentriert das kann
untersuchungsausschuss das ist meine
russen ein gewisses ziel erreicht nichts
neben ihr anwalt joachim cäsar preller
worden sind also es sind natürlich immer
größer ist das heißt also die sich
und damit ein stück weit auch
früher mal die ganze ukraine wollte hat
seit monaten wird ja über den bakken
immer mehr ziele sich ausdenken bevor
dabei den zweiten teil der wahrheit
bestandteil eines waffenstillstand seien
höchste entschädigung und da ist
richtig oder da hätten wir könnten wir
sehr gering natürlich will man dass der
messenger zum beispiel interoperabel
preise der zeitung würde ich mich
videos mit frauengeschichten aus moskau
etwas was eigentlich fatale ist in der
ich schon karl lauterbach mal in der
ihrer sicht tatsächlich teilen die
durch ihn und ich verstehe solche
repräsentant dieses landes und ich finde
hat jede woche vor allem oder eben
und ja es die was die was die deutschen
büro sie kriegt eine fette pension und
ist es wirklich unsäglich wie unser
vergessen dass putin nämlich die einheit
schon mal gemacht die haben standard den
vielleicht jetzt nicht so diese german
noch zum vergleich mit den gesamthilfen
nicht gut sein für die vielfalt in
die erkrankung wirklich lang anhaltende
erzielt für krones geschädigte vor
er gesagt weiß ich nicht aber das ist
funktionieren weil das problem ist eben
genauso anschließen da muss einiges auf
alle wieder besser schlafen wir hätten
bedarf der ukraine debattiert wie
gestoppt wird nehmen sie mal was
russische armee ist sehr viel schlechter
wie man sie donald trump nachgesagt hat
lage wäre eine solche geschichte
krieg aufhört aber man sagt und das ist
entsprechende kriterien mehr oder
interviews wie new york times überhaupt
natürlich bei den impfstoffherstellern
politik bei den journalisten deren job
bundeskanzler die
maßgeblich die spd in der andere ausrede
die das begangen hat ausgezeichnet hat
sie kann sich mal öffentlich äußern zu
angeht und ihre ängstlichkeit da haben
da kann man es auch nicht einfach abtun
den den monopolisten des ölgeschäfts
jetzt jedenfalls ein kriegsziel und
natürlich gibt es die überlegung und
mehr spaß wir könnten den frühling viel
verteidigungsministerin die spd hier
gericht
schäden haben ich habe eine kollegin die
dem prüfstand das heißt jetzt nicht dass
wesentlich mehr zu holen aber trotzdem
entschieden stellte stichwort uni leider
zuzugestehen es gibt gott lob bei den
weniger definieren und mit bezug auf die
wir haben monopole in diesen bereichen
wenig aber auf der anderen seite keine
ist es doch gerade abweichende meinungen
empfindest du die diskussion du hast uns
unserem lande oder sogar weltweit
ein argument glaube ich dass man sehr
und sagen na ja gut der ist jetzt halt
nicht wo er alles beschönigt alles noch
solchen diskussionen oder nicht also zum
als die internationale gemeinschaft
alles das gibt es nicht schröder
185 km vertritt er bereits tendenz
und die damit zum vorbild für die
gefunden warum es jetzt gerade irgendwie
zerschlagen in verschiedene große immer
natürlich gibt es auch eine gefahr der
wir den impfgegnern das wort reden
in meinem alter ist die nicht eigentlich
besser genießen das wäre jetzt eine
stimmen wir dem dann zu dass er die ost
wir ja schon während der kubakrise
lobbyist oder erteilt irgendeine
cremen mit dem historischen pflaster
zu fügen und sie sollen dem doch auch
ist die erste these vorbei für heute und
angenommen hat und die ukraine sehr viel
dazu auch eine these heute abend
jetzt wochenlang laviert hat dass wir
und die kunden und nutzer können sich ja
und das ist meine forderung der staat
außerdem sind mir einige doch sehr
ernst nehmen muss was wäre denn wenn wir
medien langsam die bereitschaft über
russische armee erhoben hat das heißt
nicht geht erst hieß es wir haben nichts
angestellt hat und da kann ich natürlich
betrachtet putin als seinen persönlichen
angeboten ukraine mit bezug eben darauf
entsprechende erfahrungen gemacht da
persönliche verbindung sondern ich finde
gerade richtig für ihn ja das ist doch
nicht mehr arbeitsfähig ist dadurch dass
einen noch mal es sind fehler gemacht
mitgebracht
zivilgesellschaftliche möglichkeit
darf nicht wegklicken der staat muss
richtig dürfte sein dass karin eines
noch große ölkonzerne und twitter darf
zu vernachlässigende größenordnung wenn
wollen das ist gar nicht mein million
bekommen weiter zu frau bislang und
überhaupt mal zu potte kommen auch
dieses thema zu schreiben und zu reden
ukraine bekommt ich meine zu erkennen
russland jetzt ein bisschen geben wer
man sieht daran wie jemand in
gar nicht aussuchen sie sind am ende zum
sie relativ am anfang corona hatte ohne
habe ich die deutschen von einer völlig
von der verteidigungsministerin
auch na ja ich wollte dafür den paul
freund und ich betone persönlichen
merkwürdige zitate des halbmasken
ein freundschaftsdienst eine echte
ansonsten bin ich natürlich auf der
uns zu berichten haben an meiner seite
worden stichwort nato-beitritt 2008 das
dieses interview ist eigentlich an
neuen seite kennen gelernt und da
tisch schieben man muss sie nur in
waffen zu liefern
sich um diese menschen kümmern laut er
die an der man kann sagen endlich und
komischerweise haben wir jetzt irgendwas
schwierigkeiten gerät auch in
ihrer these im prinzip ja es ist also
sagt uns denn dass russland dann aufhört
party zum manko vielleicht einmal kurz
gewissen grad darauf angewiesen weil wir
gm zu sein also man kann ja die fakten
man auf der anderen seite wiederum sieht
sind ja im winter kämpft ich bin auch
kein nato mitgliedsstaat zu werden aber
angeht da finde ich die spd
nicht in der hand eines einzelnen mannes
das war bei den sanktionen nicht anders
seite das natürlich muss das
scheint sich fortzusetzen
zynismus kaum zu überbieten sich dann
dass es in westlichen hauptstädten ich
höchste zeit weil eben der der korona
anderen zusammenhang bekannt um gottes
freundschaft hätte sagen müssen das war
kurz journalist und 48 stimmen dass hans
freund es ist der freund seines lebens
glaubwürdigkeitsprobleme wenn er zu
doch für den ringtausch da dann hieß es
danach
ich halte diese entscheidung jetzt diese
war spricht dauernd irgendwo in sachen
dass die versorgungsämter der
wer sagt uns denn dass nicht wieder
eben nur diesen dieser entsprechenden
dass es sind auch viele die das zu mir
strichcodes hilft aber eben auch dann
gibts ja ja richtig durch wie sich das
deutschen panzer angeht das ist keine
würde man aus heutiger sicht sicherlich
einem freund steht er tut es aber ich
gesetzlich und also politische
bleiben er hat ja etwas dunkel
ist übrig anooraq träger
schon über es geht nahtlos wie hörst
die perspektive eu beitritt und die
zu viel das ist unerträglich unsere
weiß nicht ob in allen aber in
gegeneinander
willen ich weiß nicht ob er der richtige
spricht für sich selbst die
ablichten zu lassen in der wohnung mit
alles gebrochen wird wie 1994 als der
ja das würde eben entsprechend weiter
angeht also ich wirklich läuft auch
druck im moment nachlässt dann erinnert
gesagt haben im umfeld von präsident
er hat nicht viele das ist der freund
anders entscheiden aber das rechtfertigt
westlichen hauptstädten auch in berlin
weiter gehen bei der frage ob wir waffen
angekündigt er wolle die
große leistung die zu zu sagen dann
merkwürdigen panzer zu liefern für ein
verschiedenen bundesländer die oat
szenarien ein rein und da ist nicht das
dass vieles jetzt auch schon gesagt
aufrechnen und kann einfach transparent
rede jetzt nur von der individuellen
ihnen werden ihnen kennen glaswände und
preise dass wir am ende diese politische
wollen nicht zeigt sagen jetzt habe ich
strukturen geschaffen werden indem ist
zerrissenheit zerstrittenheit heute
ist um wirklich so ein unternehmen zu
laufend am ständig gegen die cdu wenn in
freundschaft ist zerstört wo soll denn
selensky im umfeld von politikern die so
liefern und jetzt eben auch schwere
meinungsfreiheit sogar verbreitern da
worden
ausdrücken ich habe meinen beifahrer
darüber zu entscheiden haben ob einem
seines lebens und freundschaft wirkliche
das unausgesprochene konzept gibt einer
ton waffen abgegeben wurden wie
dem großen porträt wo andere gerade das
taktisches manöver das auch dazu dient
eskalieren komisch aber wenn andere
man sich an die eigenen fehler die man
nicht für das was glaube ich gerhard
geht ja darum die leute ich vertrete die
ließ den cdu-bundestagsabgeordneten
lösung dass die irgendwie zu stande
seite von schröder ich rede nicht von
ich will einfach noch mal so diese den
eine solche macht kumulation nicht geben
doch gesagt aber über impfschäden hat er
waffen und wir brauchen bei allem zu
fragen wir doch jetzt erst mal bevor ich
morgen sagen herr mützenich und der
gemacht hat worüber man wird man zur
da libyens gehen sie mal davon aus dass
leiten und nach vorne zu bringen da habe
verschiedene weitere
aufklären und ich glaube das ist schon
der in den usa dem stammland des
nato-staaten trotzdem bereits sind genau
das einzige szenario was das
ronja kammern sind ist zudem mitglied im
meine sache immer bekommt wer kümmert
kommen muss ist ja nicht falsch und
freundschaft heißt dass sie
schaden anerkannt wird ihre arbeit nicht
haus verlieren und die eigenen vier
schröder momentan macht und wie er sich
der politischen und ich würde wenn ich
lange druck gemacht haben dass olaf
seite gedrückt hat ich stelle das
lange es kann nicht sein dass wir
gibt es jetzt mutmaßungen gemeint hat
zu ihnen komme paul ist es denn keine
politischen lösung die genau das
diese jetzt regierende koalition zu
fokus darauf lenken worum geht es
ihm das gesagt hat gehen sie mal davon
haben sich ja alle impfen lassen ja sie
nicht ein wort verloren und das finde
sich darum niemand
ich große bedenken bin ich nicht dafür
kapitalismus wesentliche kräfte im
das jahr zu tun andere staaten haben sie
trotzdem glaube ich muss man sich der
bedingungslos ist das heißt man hält
kann weil das ist das ist schon sehr
äußert also dann lieber gar nicht äußern
scholz umgefallen ist und gesagt hat
beinhaltet
wände verlieren aufgrund des krieges und
beispielsweise beim rbb fest im rbb gibt
machen sogar in berlin wo wir jetzt sind
innerhalb der nato innerhalb der eu
gibt unterschiedliche und die meisten
präsidium der union schöner sie darum
das land aktuell auf twitter muss ich
wichtig und es ist ein schritt weg von
eigentlich mit dieser waffenlieferung
das noch sagen darf sie haben völlig
retten denn die ist näher am zerbrechen
frau aussagen wie sehen sie das blick
deshalb auch liefert man nicht
aus ja gehen sie mal davon aus dass er
frage stellen wie verhindert man dass es
panzerlieferungen gibt dann am
sind dem ruf des staates gefolgt waren
große leistung diese panzer zu zu sagen
schon bekannt entsprechend schwer
will den mann ist er ganz knapp drüber
ich nicht richtig finde noch wichtiger
gefährlich wir haben das ist zwar nicht
szenarien ist es einfach wichtig dass
0 anerkannte impfschäden vorkommen und
immer die letzten sind die am ende dann
okay wir liefern jetzt zumindest ein
kongress dafür sind diese internetriesen
langfristig denn natürlich ist niemand
recht was die funktionen angeht seine
auch dann zu einem freund wenn deren
vorkämpfer um unserem anspruch sie hier
es eine bereitschaft über das thema zu
sagen mit den warnhinweisen sachen
dann noch zu sagen mea culpa ist nicht
als sich so zu äußern will ein kurzes
so einer paternalistischen haltung wir
als man vielleicht öffentlich wahrnimmt
auf die meinungsfreiheit dass herr maske
nicht darüber hinausgeht weil ich glaube
schwere waffen zu liefern und deswegen
nachmittag gibt es die also das ist ein
entschlossen richtig wichtige waffen und
russland nicht man traute russland
der eigner von twitter bei sich
schweren fehler macht und man kann sogar
sehr brav sozusagen und jetzt erwarten
reden und
position in der in der russischen kriegs
als die entschädigungsfrage ist
andere länder die ukraine mit waffen und
ausgeblendet twitter ist aktuell ist
weiß auch wahrscheinlich wegen
bei 48 tagesaktuell zu informieren
das in der schärfe öffentlich nicht
in hessen wo ich herkomme ebenfalls 0
zu zerschlagen
teilweise so aufgespielt donald trump
wenn putin die möglichkeit hat mehr zu
damit hat es ja auch übernahmen die
hier im raum daran interessiert dass
mein ding also ich übersetzte so ein
haben jetzt entschieden was gut für euch
deshalb nicht und man will dass alle
programm na ja so zu äußern wie er ist
chaos dass ich mir in dieser spd und die
sprechen das ist ein fakt nicht fertig
ja uli hat natürlich völlig recht also
diese diese frage wie die ukraine
dann zu ihm halten wenn er zum
dann sind die ja linker als die cdu hier
internationalem druck und im streit
überhaupt dass wir über diese
moderne waffen sondern man ist dabei
auch nicht die oase der meinungsfreiheit
sagen will der ist ja nicht blöd dass
was er durch twitter ausgelöst hat ist
in der russischen energiewirtschaft da
ist sondern wirklich zu sagen ja das
ein bisschen selbstkritik wäre bei den
meinungsfreiheit zu wahren so gut dass
noch nicht sie sagen das kann lange
verantwortung an der stelle und auch
dieser krieg sich endlos hinzieht es
bisschen naja ihr könnt mich irgendwie
bekommen als das dann wird er das auf
menschen anerkannt worden sind mit ihm
sie wirklich dass ihnen auch geholfen
eben mit schweren waffen beliefern damit
schalten wir nun direkt zu meinem
impfschäden reden ja wir wurden ja in
ja aber das wollen wir der nase von
jetzt auch beim thema schwere waffen
russischen truppen aus dem land
hat schon viel chaos erlebt kaum hätte
richtig durch die ausgabe von
verbrecher wird und das ist in diesem
an der stelle momentan tut oder im
irgendwie altes gerät fit zu machen
wo gibt es denn so was sie wollen die
unterstützt wird kann die frage sein an
sind das sind wirklich die vorteile und
immer noch sozialdemokrat er war es ein
dauern sie brauchen auch leopard sie
er da ist jetzt erst mal behauptet ist
mal ne ich finde ganz ehrlich das ist
kollegen bild vize und fiel nach trost
glaube ich eine will also da gibt
wird und da erleben sie beim
medien angebracht denn das thema ist tot
das ist das was ich ja auch gerade
verschwinden und das gesamte territorium
die ich will euch sagen sie sollen auf
journalismus einfach die verlautbarungen
stehen kann das nicht richtig sein die
lieferungen innerhalb der koalition gar
den letzten jahren einfach bestritten
muss darum gehen dass wir natürlich dass
sollte man ihm den fahrrad abnehmen man
nicht zerschlagen
vorstellen können aber welche partei für
übrigen noch ein stichwort nord stream 1
ganzes leben lang ich setze mich dagegen
richtig dass er gesperrt wurde von
rechtsradikalen und und hessen wollen
verlässlichkeit die wir irgendwie
das könnt ihr haben und wir sind in der
fall offensichtlich so was ist die basis
nun eine seite ich finde dass es
brauchen auch marder warum ist das so
damit man damit man sich nicht ständig
ich der punkt den wir beantworten müssen
der sich entscheidet ob die ampel
wieder an die ukraine geht jetzt
berichtet habe daß man leopard dass man
als völlig unerheblich ab und zu gibt es
geschwiegen worden es gibt
nicht mehr anders geht die spd dann
auch als repräsentant dieses landes ist
leute haben vertraut auf die impfung auf
paul ronzheimer er berichtet seit drei
versorgungsämtern der länder ja also
twitter donald trump ja also in dem fall
flüge normal und dann rufe ich jetzt so
es zu einer friedensverhandlungen kommt
darstellen müssen gerade als deutschland
wir auch nicht haben oder also radikal
die fläche im don was ist ganz anders
ein bisschen dagegen zur wehr dass sie
wurde unter gerhard schröder beschlossen
unabhängig davon ob das realistisch ist
mich den wirklich überraschenden
und da ist zurückhaltung von deutscher
beispielsweise wenn ich das richtig sehe
mader will aber in ihrer verzweiflung
koalition in zukunft hat oder nicht jede
da mal ein fall aber das ist völlig
dieser freundschaft ganz sicher kann man
problematisch dass es immer
an ich glaube da war gerade was mit der
irgendwann mal ein lenkt sondern wir
dass es zu
den vorwurf anhören muss dass man nichts
lage euch zu impfen und ihr könnt es
das was gesagt worden ist und wie bei
halte ich es für richtig das ist auch
waffenstillstandsverhandlungen kommt
muss ich nicht weil ich als
monaten täglich aus der ukraine erst
eine ablehnungshaltung so können wir
mir ein bisschen alle beide unterstellen
die erkenntnis die sie in der
unerheblich wir merken es ist doch
das hat auch niemand so klippstein die
als in kiew dort gibt es eine offene
eindruck macht ist die geschlossenheit
so hetzer nicht natürlich nicht
seite meines erachtens momentan die
oder nicht das ist die stimmung in der
und der werden wir im eben momentan
problematisch wenn
nicht mehr im rahmen der
aber auch dafür ich wiederhole mich ein
täten aber man will in wahrheit nichts
müssen da wirklich auch mal wieder vor
sind die ukraine bei dem was sie in den
einfach in anspruch nehme ich meine das
politische lager heißt es sucht sich die
jedem medikament auch beim impfstoff
wissenschaft durchsetzt dass jüngere
scheibe gehören herum hat kein tun man
nur mutmaßen ganz sicher dass beide aus
deutlich sage ich mal wie kann es sein
ich würde uli hoeneß mit herrn putin
cdu-politikern antworten ich würde mir
meinungsfreiheit oder nicht
bevölkerung realismus hieße in diesem
der grünen also wir dürfen ja nicht
falschen
schlacht dort gibt es keine
erheblich auch wenn das bezogen auf die
als allgemeines gesetz machen man sollte
die welle kommen und das erwarte ich
beim umkämpften kiew und jetzt aus dem
jemand in einem solchen monopolsituation
nicht gerecht und ich bin mir auch
meinungsfreiheit sondern da ist jemand
ist ja erst mal ein tolles angebot ich
these von der für die nächste sendung
männer bis 35 jahre ganz besonders
bei so viel gemeldeten ihm stehen dass
vergangenen wochen und monaten aus
koalition die ihr angemessen ist und
vergleichen das tue ich nicht ich rede
bisschen sind natürlich war für
kann es zu nebenwirkungen zu schweren
verein der sich auch noch an der debatte
vergessen dass das mal eine grund
wünschen dass angela merkel mal in ihrem
jetzt haben wir gehört wie er hier
tun sondern das ist das ziel das
möglichkeiten für die ukrainische armee
auch von einem bundeskanzler
sicher hätten wir als union diese woche
fall dass man sich damit abfindet der
deutschen staatsbürgern verbieten als
weil ich mich nicht den ganzen tag mit
der tatsächlich
gesamtzahl der impfungen nicht
hoffe es vorteile zeigen aber auch sowas
ärmlichen sozialen verhältnissen kommen
ulli wird wessen angela merkel zu tun
osten der ukraine in der stadt groß war
deutschland gehört haben der erst einmal
versuchen die scheite wieder aufzubauen
lieferung notwendig denn ich glaube
aber der schlager schlagerstar in heißen
wohnzimmer fotografiert wird oder in
es null anerkannte fälle gibt es musste
er hat vor einigen wochen eine große
nebenwirkungen kommen und wenn das
pazifistische partei war und als es um
wahnsinnig viel sind aber die
anfällig sind für
sich zu verstecken und dann wieder
politische kriegsziel heißt putin krieg
nur davon was es bedeutet wenn man ein
ist und twitter ist ohnehin ein von mir
die aufstände die wir am sechsten januar
aggressor macht beute in der ukraine
sanktion
rechtsradikalen und hetzern rum
beteiligen möchte ich muss das ja hier
und sich sehr verwandt fühlen in der
die habe ich schon gehabt hier in der
nicht verschweigen und datenlage
deswegen bedanke ich mich jetzt hier
den antrag nicht eingebracht im
ihrem büro und dass sie mal ein paar
freudig gestimmt dass rolf mützenich
betroffenen menschen wenn man die
passiert ist muss man sie auch großzügig
ansprache im deutschen bundestag
nicht dass putin es ein denkt wenn die
führungspositionen in russischen
herzmuskelentzündungen durch impfungen
sendung war gut doch noch mal machen wir
ich noch mal sagen in berlin oder in
freund fallen lässt oder verrät was das
der ost ukraine und dann ist frieden und
anzugreifen sondern das ist diese offene
irgendwas wird er kriegen damit der
den kosovo krieg ging damals mit joschka
aufbessern da sind wir doch zum grämen
hinsicht ganz sicher auch dass putin
sätze sagt was sie für putin gesagt hat
zusammenzählt gibt es auch schon
entsprechende koalition in berlin
schon mal einmal bei paul schallte es
deutschen bundestag gebe es kein antrag
fühlen er kann ja leider nicht im studio
sie wird die wird den würde ich da
und nicht ändern das ist ja unsinn
der ukraine von der lage die du in kiew
staatsunternehmen zu übernehmen dann
erhalten aber in taten muss man sagen
gesamte welt gegen ihn steht ich glaube
das gibt dann zu klassifizierungen die
erkleckliche zahlen mit interessiert
hessen und ein bundesländer sind
krieg aufhört ich würde am liebsten
selbst der spielt mittlerweile in der
sein ich bin froh wenn er wieder hier
etwas kritisch begutachtet des
entschädigen ja und das ist nicht der
dann sind die russisch orientierten
individuell bedeutet das hat mich sehr
gehen jetzt in eine ganz kurze
gerade nicht mehr möglich aber seine
gesehen haben
sie wartet getan hat sie waren für putin
gefährliche schlacht die sie dort führen
der ampelkoalition
begegnen also jedenfalls ein mann der
und scholz muss sehr aufpassen dass ihm
bekommen bei der these und jetzt machen
fischer ist heftige debatten gab in der
ist im leider echt wenig gefolgt ist
gerd schröder zwei adoptivkinder besorgt
dann haben wir schlechte karten denn er
dort wollen sind ex ölkonzern geworden
ist
wirklich anerkannt zu werden als
könnte er das nicht mehr warum tut man
für uns schon mal weiter und damit muss
erlebt hast ja wir sind auf dem weg in
dabei wie dieses thema weggedrückt
unterbrechung und dann wird herr über
nicht diese realistische lösung sehen
geschürt hat und der natürlich durch
these debattieren auf zu ende gehen
russisch sprechenden leuten fallen kann
der jetzt entsprechend diese woche
meinungsbildung
ukrainischen politik eine rolle der
wichtiger als schröder schröder war
fall das ist mein aufreger java sind im
müssen aber mich hat heute etwas anderes
hat verbündete bei denen ich nicht
die grünen nicht ausbrechen und dann
wir die letzte these von ihnen frau käme
lange gequält und ich glaube auch
die seine arbeit für impfgeschädigte
jetzt ich will ein bisschen wasser in
partei und die nehme ich gar nicht mehr
hat in moskau diese kinder hätte
man sich glaube ich beschäftigen und
ist alle privatisiert und
worden ist wie so viele andere corona
impfgeschädigte oder ist es eigentlich
spd-fraktionschef überstimmt wurde das
entschieden wird da bin ich mir nicht
bestimmt wo die grenzen der
das nicht und fordert ihn ständig auf er
russland in der ost ukraine und die west
ich hänge tut mir leid einer idealisten
nicht mehr kanzler als nord stream 2
also mit einfach die ukrainische armee
hoch spannende debatte und vor allem und
eine meinung ist ein wort das
auch die fdp folgt also ich sehe eher
deshalb noch mal danke das ist tun eine
wahr bei den grünen nämlich verstanden
schröder wird das lange quälen wenn er
darauf wetten würde dass sie irgendwann
ganz so sicher also ich glaube was die
meinungsfreiheit verlaufen das geht
stehen es ist also nicht so dass jede
ja meine these dreht sich um eine maske
sein amt oder dann ex amt eine so große
nicht also nicht wirklich wenn sich die
schröder in seinem alter in deutschland
sprechen denn er vertritt
kritische themen weggedrückt worden sind
oder scholz doch schon eine art
möchte auf die positionen verzichten man
den wein gießen ich kann mich der
nicht vorzeitig aufgegeben wird
haben das will man freiheit und
regulierungen dann gebe ich doch noch
lösung an ich würde gerne sehen dass der
gebaut worden ist und wer die partnern
überhaupt nicht sondern dann muss man
das tun würde das die freundschaft
gegen ihn stehen
überlegung noch vielleicht warum das so
spd angeht und ihre zerrissenheit was
ukraine wo kiew liegt nah an polen darf
euphorie wegen der jetzt beschlossenen
heißt sie sind nicht ganz falsch glaube
nicht mehr bekommen können und
befindlichkeitsstörung nach einer
beispielsweise die völlige isolierung
innenpolitische motive als
kehrtwende hingelegt hat also das wird
in deutschland diskutiert wird und wie
kann es ihm einfach verbieten das ist
183 mandanten wenn es richtig gelesen
durchgesetzt hat war angela merkel und
ich stimme dir voll zu das ist auch das
mal hierhin aber machen dass überall
aggressor rausgeworfen wird aus der
politik die er letztendlich vorgaben
eben eine konkurrenz zwischen
demokratie waren will dass das am ende
aber er wird dann einlenken wenn er
impfung darunter fällt nein die
ja twitter gekauft hat und jetzt die
einseitig ist jedenfalls nicht
wir haben ja wirklich ein kriegs verlauf
das thema angeht ja das ist
verschwiegen wird ja man denkt in den
verschiedenen diensten herstellen und
lieferungen von leopard-panzern nicht
einsetzen den balken zum doppel zu
außenpolitische auf jeden fall keine
hier erst einmal ganz grundsätzlich
keine besonderen einschränkung das recht
anhängerschaft hatte dass er
auch in europa diskutiert wird denn
ukraine und zwar überall und zwar auch
habe also nach der kurzen unterbrechung
macht für die behörden ja nicht ändert
von ungeimpften die sich täglich am
was ich aus dem politischen berlin
wer verhindert hat dass die ukraine in
mandanten die ich in meiner anweisen
ich mit dieser bezeichnung also wenn ich
in die eu eintreten der rest wird
schröder ist hat dafür
gegen einen aggressor putin eben nicht
offensichtlich ich glaube aber das ist
große diskussion entstanden ist wie viel
ausgewogen das ist auch mein eindruck
vielleicht wär vielleicht doch du kannst
die müssen in
einfach keine militärischen erfolge mehr
machen was für regulierungen könnte man
höhere seit beginn des krieges schon
immer dann wenn man wenn politiker wenn
sind wir wieder hier das gleiche
höchsten politischen kreisen bot das
ernsthaften versuch der ukraine zu
der sehr schwer einzuschätzen ist allein
brandgefährlich war in dieser in dieser
anschließen das ist ja altes gerät das
neutral das scheint mir in berlin
die nato kommt war angela merkel und
praxis vertrete haben schwerste
von der krim dass man ihn besiegt ist
die beiden koalitionspartner gibt die
dann ist dieser weg kein gangbarer weg
testen lassen müssen damit sie arbeiten
verantwortung geht da eigentlich auch
dann brauchen regulierung natürlich auf
davor ich glaube man hat schon vor
irgendeiner form von kollektiven händen
wirklich sichtbar erzielen kann und wenn
ein allgemeines gesetz machen es werden
feinheiten sprechen unser kollege julian
wenn man das thema so ein bisschen zur
twitter drei minuten anguckt ist ein tag
denn als schröder moskau war musste auch
experten dafür eintreten dass
die bundeswehr gar nicht mehr hat und
wenn man da zurück schaut auf die jahre
helfen august dann können sie den etwas
mit ausschließlich mit verhandlungen
selbst ein sehr großes interesse haben
schwere nachteile in kauf genommen er
erkrankungen zum beispiel myokarditis
mit einher und ich glaube wir können
gedacht zu werden das meint herr scholz
können aber die wurden ja trotzdem zur
herzschlag also da kann ich dann ein
seite drückt dass man damit der
dann ist der weg an die hersteller heran
beginn des krieges versucht 100 events
die vokabel mehrfach gefallen aber mir
blase die ja keine blase riesen man den
ja auch alle möglichen leute unter und
für mich gelaufen dann habe ich so viel
aufgrund der tatsache dass jemand hier
europäischer ebene also weltweit wird
sein und sei es der die kollektive
das wird viele wochen dauern bis die
röcke hat dazu ja einige dinge enthüllt
deutschland noch mehr panzer liefern
an dem sechs meter tisch platz nehmen
ihrer kanzlerschaft muss man sagen sie
seite geschoben sie konnten nicht leben
das thema voranzubringen und jemand wie
positives an dem kurs von
geht sondern erst einmal militärisch und
das ist eine herzmuskelerkrankung
er vielleicht einen kleinen
schlechte laune angestaut dass ich kann
gehen irgendeine art von
zu gehen und dort im vergleich zu
panzer so hergerichtet sind dass sie
ist sein ruf ist erledigt in deutschland
das nicht funktionieren das heißt es
festhalten die großen plattformen die
also der der putin hatte nicht anders
mit einem wort erstens machen sie sich
achtungserfolg selbst verkaufen kann vor
sollen dann wird gesagt na ja wir müssen
wenn er sagt wenn ich nichts tue ist das
impfkampagne nützt genau das gegenteil
dass sanktionen gestellt viele leute und
weisheit der börse so viel gibt hot
scheint es im westen in den nato statt
deswegen finde ich auch die grünen
hat in der hinsicht viel falsch gemacht
dass nicht genügend munition da ist dass
frau strack zimmermann als sehr
den angriffskrieg begonnen hat von dem
einsatzfähig werden dann müssen auch
verhandlungslösung zu drücken
einem gesamt kurs da hatte ich erst mal
muss eigentlich beschränkt sein wie viel
schließen entweder renten oder
sinus venenthrombosen schlaganfälle
weitgehend er ist isoliert er ist einsam
dass sanktionen gestellt natürlich kann
großen sozialen netzwerke sie tragen
insbesondere annalena baerbock und
mir jemanden blumenstrauß schenken dass
behandelt wie andere besucher und er hat
es ewig dauern wir dass diese panzer
da heute ja alle gelernt haben möchte
verdient dadurch dass sie über das thema
leute daran geübt und trainiert werden
neutralität wie österreich das wir ja
auch führung das ist kein witz das ist
insbesondere in berlin diese
ja auch die nato-staaten schützen das
abfindungszahlungen der juristisch
engagiert und zwar von anfang an da
prozent eine person oder eine gruppe von
ist der fall das feld das entschieden
man deutschen verbieten in der
wir interesse also gut aber ich glaube
zurück aber zumindest an dem jetzigen
vor vor seinem land vor und darum will
kammer kann man vielleicht auch sagen
robert habeck der übrigens schon im
ich glaube keiner so richtig sagen kann
kommen also das ist das große problem
entschlossenheit ihn zu besiegen nicht
noch halb so schlimm kann man sagen dann
reden und es an die oberfläche ziehen
ihn mit leeren händen wieder
jeden tag mehr dazu bei wie
autoimmunerkrankungen und die reihe dass
auch nicht zynisch muss sondern das ist
dass die kritiker sich meine der mann
das dauert endlos lang das ist also ein
russischen energiewirtschaft
bessere weg trotzdem für nicht das nicht
schritt das ist ein schritt in die
fortschritte zu machen also ihre kritik
sommer also vor den wahlen hier
ist aus meiner sicht ein lächerliches
weggeschickt hat nichts mitgebracht
gibt darf man doch nicht den querdenkern
ich gern mal wissen hat angela merkel
führungspositionen zu übernehmen da
personen an teilhaben können einem
jetzt nicht das aber macht das besser
meinungsbildung auch in unseren
geht es dann um die frage aber wie viel
und ich glaube um diesem argument der
was er in einer woche tun wird was er in
zu geben und damit beenden wir die these
vielleicht ernst gemeint naja aber es
nicht mal einen humanitären korridor für
richtige richtung aus meiner sicht es
und den menschen ein bisschen
er hat viele ehrungen und auszeichnungen
auch gelernt das möchte ich gern mal
war im april letzten jahres der reichste
argument denn hier in der ukraine wo ich
richtig dass ich das höre stimmen sie
sich noch unermesslich fortsetzen ist es
defensivwaffen für die ukraine gefordert
an der spd da gehe ich mit aber ihre
macht erst ein paar überlegungen wie er
gerät das gar nicht aktuell gebraucht
gesellschaften in unseren demokratien
militär erlaubt in russland aber noch
musst du nicht im kopf ich würde das
überlassen im internet die darüber
unternehmen da kann man quoren sagen
ich einfach nochmal betonen warum es
gerechtigkeit verschaffen hoffentlich
mario pohl oder irgendetwas 24 stunden
ist mehr als wir noch vor ein paar tagen
stattfindet deswegen hat eine maske auch
hat die spielen eine wirklich sehr sehr
gibt doch mittlerweile auch situationen
sehen setzen sie machen ihren einfluss
vier und zwei stunden ein moderner ganz
dem zu einem untersuchungsausschuss ist
kritik an der gesamten koalition da
da strukturen verändern will aber dass
werden kann im kampf um die ost ukraine
nato was ich dort genannt habe das ist
natürlich immer wieder als ist einfach
gerade stehe hier passiert nichts
von frau bislang danke ein paar wir
wirklich wichtig ist dass man dass
mann zum beispiel war er schon der
viel schlimmer sind im die
wohlfeil berichtet und der staat tut
aus der vergangenheit verloren
zweitens bin ich der meinung man sieht
also nicht über 75 prozent oder nicht
positive rolle momentan und werden ja
großes leid bei den menschen die
ein dass sie sich mal den nächster zeit
würde ich jetzt ein bisschen dagegen
kurz in ihren reihen wann ist ihnen denn
in denen britische soldaten an neuen
und ich bin langsam so weit dass ich den
wäldern das ist ja mal sein vermögen
anderes als dass die nato geschützt wird
deutschland ein bisschen mutiger würden
hören uns morgen wieder und kommen jetzt
gesehen haben es war wirklich dieses
nochmal für die impfung also ob es den
eine sehr sehr große verantwortung an
feuerpause nichts hat er mitgebracht
räumt er wieder in der leitung danach
weil andere sanktionen sind auch als
äußert zu dem was sie getan hat niemand
eine von vielen ausreden gewesen also
wir da rauskommen will weiß ich nicht
auch daran es wäre jetzt höchste zeit
das was was ich ja immer glaube ist das
nichts ja das spielt ja auch bei anderen
auch vom deutschen von der deutschen
vollständig aus ihrem leben gerissen
über 50 das wäre so eine möglichkeit was
hängt immer ein bisschen vom tesla
ich fand das so nett mit der german
ganzen untersuchungsausschuss braucht
zu der these von hans ulrich jörges der
der stelle der gerecht werden muss das
satz den urlaub scholz mehrfach gesagt
die bundesregierung ein bisschen mehr
waffen techniken neue waffentechnologie
darfst du direkt und die grünen nur noch
lange zögern ich finde ist tatsächlich
aktienkurs ab aber hat er sogar schon
und zwar dadurch dass wladimir putins
schönes sein anwalt jan tisch ich wollte
entgegen jahr höher als normale fällt in
wenn ich mit deutschen politikern
angst wann es ihnen denn die german
sind die ihre familie nicht mehr
dabei hat sich entschlossen
weiß ich nicht aber was es braucht ist
die gesamte corona politik in zwei
bevölkerung in dem sinne belohnt das
und wenn wir wenn wir heute bilder sehen
einmal jetzt zurück das er gerade kurz
sagt dass die energiepolitik in den
monopol richtigen geben muss dass es
man machen könnte auf europäischer ebene
insbesondere von der spd gesprochen habe
sich mit gerhard schröder aber fast ja
ausgebildet werden das sind alle
jeff bezos einmal überrannt gehabt ist
heißt wir müssen die meinungsfreiheit
aussagen harry man würde ihm
hat er sich so merkwürdig anhört selbst
versorgen können die auch ihren beruf
truppen zurückgedrängt werden dadurch
angst um das thema abzurunden das erste
dann auch ist auf jeden fall mal eine
ein bisschen peinlich dass deutschland
schützen und auf der anderen seite ist
rausgeflogen aus der leitung jetzt
rutschen
letzten jahren ohne fehler ist ganz klar
den rücken ich bin genau anderer die
also in deutschland alleine nutzt das ja
jahren alles was es da gegeben hat das
und zwar etwas anders als ich das in den
möglicherweise sogar gefallen tun weil
in den vergangenen monaten habe ich
franzosen machen das und einige
dass die ukrainische armee gegen diese
wie die beiden sich begegnet sie in den
ein must geht es nicht vielleicht
eben nicht mehr ausüben können und es
dass es eine ordnungsbusse struktur
beliebteste politikerin oder ministerin
mal begegnet hier nicht nur weil die
wenn ich nichts tue ist das führung dass
immer von globaler verantwortung spricht
erklärung ich glaube ich die datenlage
sollte er wieder da sein dann würde ich
wir müssen erkennen dass fehler gemacht
man ihm die entscheidung abnimmt er kann
das netz eben kein recht der raum und
eine runde überhaupt nichts und darauf
einfach der visionär er brauche ich
vergangenen jahren an sehen wir immer
letzten tagen gehört und gelesen habe
eigentlich jede woche eine neue ausrede
versagen des staates für mich ist das
deutschlands ist sie sagen saison trafen
nicht zu verraten und das ist eine ich
weil was sie ja sagen ist es wird in den
worden sind aber ich finde das
und dann in solchen situationen sich
ihn nämlich direkt einmal fragen ja das
ist fraglich bei sehr viel ob sie
dass schröder putin umarmt aber nicht
geben muss in der ich nicht zu viel
gerhard schröder hat sich in der new
ziemlich durchgängig der fall gewesen in
gehört warum bestimmt dinge jetzt doch
man diesen satz ernst nehmen muss ich
rechtfertigt er trotzdem auf der anderen
wenn man sogar weltweit auch verstehen
ländern zum teil sehr unterschiedlich
überhaupt in früheres leben werden
umgekehrt also da ist schon was wahres
wiederhole noch mal eine persönliche
motivation die mir sogar respekt
abnötigt obwohl putin ein verbrecher ist
aber das kann nicht nachvollziehen weil
ich eine eigene erfahrung gemacht habe
die nicht so schwerwiegend ist das zu
tun
zu einem freund zu halten und ihnen
nicht zu verraten kostet viel kraft ich
habe diese kraft nicht gehabt als ich
meine freundschaft zu uli hoeneß
zerstört habe ich war eingeladen in eine
talkshow
in der ard
bei günther jauch als
hoeneß wegen seiner steuerhinterziehung
es ging um knapp 30 millionen zu einer
gefängnisstrafe verurteilt worden war da
wurde ich heftig mit kritischen fragen
unter druck gesetzt und ich habe dann
gesagt dass ich steuerhinterziehung in
diesem ausmaß für asozial halte das war
meine politische überzeugung aber es ist
natürlich
uli hoeneß nicht gerecht geworden
er hat die sendung nicht gesehen er war
schon zu bett gegangen an diesem abend
aber seine frau hat sie gesehen und als
seine frau zu ihm gekommen ist hat sie
geweint da war mein verhältnis zu ihm
meine freundschaft zu ihm erledigt und
ich habe das immer sie es auch heute
noch als den fehler meines lebens
betrachtet
dann würde ich sagen sollten sie ohne
hoeneß anrufen und sich entschuldigen
ich finde es sehr schwierig die herrn
hoeneß und wladimir putin zu vergleich
aus gilt nicht
und ich bin die erste die gar schröder
ermutigt wenn wladimir putin in den haag
in haft sitzt den mal besuchen zu gehen
und ihn wenn er dort seine haft für die
kriegsverbrechen begeht absitzt und zu
recht dort inhaftiert ist da
vorbeizugehen und wladimir putin gute
[Musik]